ah
[Música]
bienvenidos a elecciones 2022 un tour
por francia este programa donde
analizamos los principales temas de la
campaña electoral francesa tomamos
dirección hacia norte
e
[Música]
históricamente conocida como la bella
durmiente' el aumento de la población en
nantes en los últimos años ha coincidido
con un incremento de la criminalidad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero suelo decir que es menos del mundo
nos atrapó sin antes vivir un aumento
significativo en 2016 y 2017 de un tipo
de inseguridad nueva que no habíamos
conocido antes
quien ha sido agredido al salir del
trabajo o en su vida diaria o en el
trabajo
todo el tiempo nos molesta nos sigue nos
insultan
tantas cosas que no deberían ocurrir nos
al salir a la calle
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero la seguridad no sólo preocupa a los
habitantes de nantes sino que es un tema
central de la campaña electoral y por lo
tanto incumbe a todos los franceses
las estadísticas sobre seguridad en
francia pueden preocupar a quien las lea
los delitos violentos que incluyen el
asesinato e intento de asesinato están
en alza el número de casos se ha
duplicado en los diez últimos años
llegando a 4500 en 2020 una tendencia
que se refleja también en la violencia
relacionada con las pandillas con 357
incidentes reportados en 2020 frente a
los 228 del año anterior
mientras tanto los casos denunciados de
violencia sexual se duplicaron con
creces entre 2010 y 2019 y más de la
mitad están relacionados con menores
es imposible decir sin embargo como
influyó el movimiento de denuncia mito
en esta mayor visibilidad de los delitos
pero hay razones también para estar
tranquilos el número anual de casos de
violencia física ha permanecido
relativamente estable en los años
recientes con 710 mil casos denunciados
en 2018 un poco por debajo de los 776
mil reportados en 2016 los robos no
violentos están también en descenso en
lo que respecta a la percepción de la
violencia es importante saber con quién
hablas
desempleados mujeres extranjeros dicen
sentirse menos seguros que el resto de
la población
bajo el paraguas de france 24
preguntamos a los franceses cómo viven
este aumento de la inseguridad
es muy complicado ser mujer de noche en
antes
todo el tiempo nos molesta nos sigue nos
insultan
tantas cosas que no deberían ocurrir nos
al salir a la calle
es un tema que personalmente me resulta
importante tengo un colega que fue
golpeado hasta morir en una discoteca
tengo un amigo que quedó tetrapléjico y
está en silla de ruedas porque le
intentaron robar un teléfonos celulares
tengo amigas mujeres que son acosadas
regularmente
entonces son cosas que vive cada nantes
o nantes en su vida cotidiana
porque hay inseguridad
para mí son personas que tienen
problemas en su vida diaria
y que llegan a un límite
y utilizan otros medios para salir
adelante
por primera vez la ciudad de nantes abre
las puertas de su centro de
videovigilancia a un canal de televisión
allí nos reunimos con pascal bolo
director adjunto de la seguridad de
nantes
para acá el bolo cómo se explica este
aumento de la inseguridad nantes en los
últimos años
antes era la excepción sólo en 2014 2015
llegamos aquí a los mismos niveles de
inseguridad que ya conocía la mayoría de
las grandes ciudades
por eso el estado nos mantendría con una
dotación insuficiente de policías
nacionales
pero suelo decir que la misma del mundo
nos atrapó
y nantes vivió un aumento significativo
en 2016 y 2017
y un tipo de inseguridad nueva que no
habíamos conocido antes asigna
delincuencia de actuación con robos de
teléfonos
carteros robos de joyas y otros actos
que de noche podían volverse violentos
cuáles son las causas de esta
inseguridad
la primera es la explosión del tráfico
internacional de drogas
casi todos los hechos violentos que
ocurren ya sea en el centro de la ciudad
o en los barrios populares
tienen relación directa con el tráfico
de drogas
además tras la guerra de los balcanes
barco hubo un aumento significativo del
número de armas a ojo
nosotros reclamamos a la policía
nacional que había mucho arsenal
circulando
pero no respondieron que no
que no habían encontrado nada ahora
estamos viendo que esas armas son
utilizadas
y un tercer elemento importante de este
tipo de delincuencia es el desorden del
mundo
tenemos muchos jóvenes migrantes que
huían de la guerra y la miseria
llegaban antes a otras ciudades
pero que no pueden ser regularizados
deberían regresar a lampedusa
hacer sus demandas de asilo
y tampoco son dispensables debido a la
crisis sanitaria
porque sus países de origen no son un
destino seguro
porque ellos no quieren regresar
porque sus países rechazan su
repatriación debido a la crisis
sanitaria
así que nos encontramos que una
población de jóvenes a veces muy jóvenes
que dicen ser menores pero que quizás
razón y que son presa fácil de
traficantes de drogas o cigarrillos
hay refuerzos que han llegado por
ejemplo una decena de policías es
suficiente para pagar este problema si
es suficiente y los primeros resultados
lo demuestran
gracias a los esfuerzos policiales
gracias a esos 70 efectivos municipales
adicionales
podremos multiplicar las rondas de
vigilancia
un regreso al policía de terreno
conocido por todos
que va al encuentro de los comerciantes
y que está al servicio de los habitantes
que va a pacificar el ambiente en
general es
[Música]
disuadir informar y con la ayuda del
centro de videovigilancia donde nos
encontramos
para poder constatar las infracciones
dilucidar una serie de casos o iniciar
una colaboración entre un operador en el
centro de vigilancia y una patrulla en
el carrito
que otras medidas se están implementando
y se están inspirando en alguna ciudad
concreta
claro que miramos lo que se hace en
otros lugares a las mismas causas
generan normalmente los mismos efectos
nuestra ideas en los más pragmáticos
posibles le pongo el ejemplo de la vídeo
protección
no vamos a multiplicar las cámaras
porque si para competir con misa
pues además del dispositivo de seguridad
tenemos otros de mediación para aumentar
nuestra presencia en él de renuncio
socorrer a quienes lo necesiten y
liberar a los policías municipales y
nacionales de tareas superficiales
eso permitirá a la policía nacional
ocuparse de aquello donde es
irreemplazable
es decir el combate contra el tráfico de
drogas y de armas
muchas gracias para carvalho por esta
entrevista electricidad
[Música]
mientras las autoridades de nantes
luchan contra la delincuencia los
propietarios de bares y restaurantes
quieren atraer nuevamente a ese público
con miedo y han decidido tomar la
seguridad en sus manos la historia de
karina ya buff
antes de empezar su turno idioma hace la
ronda por los cafés en el centro de la
ciudad
hace tres años este guardia de seguridad
creó un grupo en redes sociales para los
profesionales del ocio nocturno el
objetivo es intercambiar información
un guardia de seguridad reporta que
estos tres individuos son carteristas
que están robando a los transeúntes
nos avisan en tiempo real solo lo que
ocurre en otros lugares eso nos ayuda a
prepararnos en caso de que vengan aquí
el grupo tiene más de 800 miembros
incluyendo a antoine en los últimos dos
años han entrado a robar dos veces en su
local como se ve en estas imágenes
firmadas
entraron miraron detrás de la barra y se
fueron sin llevarse nada y la segunda
vez estuvieron 45 minutos buscando
tratando de abrir y sacar la caja fuerte
pero no pudieron después de eso es
complicado hacer que todo funcione con
el seguro en algún momento hay que
buscar soluciones la solución es que
nadie les ha podido dar por lo general
esa alcaldía contra la perfectura la
prefectura el estado y la alcaldía no
nos dan los medios así que debemos
encontrar soluciones antes del
resurgimiento de los robos y asaltos el
estado y la ciudad han empezado a
reforzar la presencia de patrullas en
las calles pero estos dueños de bares y
empleados dicen que no es suficiente
quien ha sido atacado al salir del
trabajo durante su día a día o incluso
en el lugar de trabajo
les aseguro que no hay nada de que
avergonzarse
en la sesión anterior eran 8 creo
podemos
aquí les enseñan defensa personal
hago 300 euros al mes de estacionamiento
llevo a mis colegas todas las noches
porque no quiero cruzar la ciudad a pie
ni que me siguen por la calle ya me han
amenazado antes con un cuchillo por eso
yo siempre me devuelvo en bicicleta a
las 3 de la mañana el tranvía no
funciona
logré aferrarme a mi bicicleta para no
caerme y lastimarme pero me empujaron
muy fuerte se llevaron todo lo que tenía
esta es la tercera sesión y para los
dueños del parque la organizan esta
actividad es necesaria
ahora se volvió un problema a la hora de
contratar de empleados y también es un
problema para los clientes algunos ya no
quieren venir al centro de nantes por
los riesgos de seguridad dueños y
empleados aprenden defensa personal
mientras esperan la llegada de los
refuerzos se espera que haya 50 nuevos
oficiales de policía en antes de este
año
[Música]
y hasta aquí este capítulo de nuestro
tour por francia en la ciudad de nantes
nos dirigimos aún más al norte a la
ciudad de lille donde hablaremos de
educación hasta pronto
[Música]